point supervision as far as i understand
and she talks about statistical rigor in
genomics
thank you so much
thank you so much dr peter beulah for
the introduction and it is my great
honor to be here to present and actually
this is my first in-person presentation
at berkeley after i graduated in 2013.
so to me this is very special and a
great honor
so i named my my group as the junction
of statistics and biology partly because
my last name is so common and another
reason is that i had training in both
biology and statistics
so my first encounter of i would say
genomics and bioinformatics was in 2007
at that time i was just a fresh
undergraduate from china and i came here
and i spent a gap year working with
peter and haiyan because i was trying to
switch my field and trying to be more
quantitative and peter actually showed
me this this image this nature paper
which is the pilot project from encode
which nancy just introduced so i'm very
grateful that i don't have to go through
the background again so that one was
phenomenal at that time and i was so
impressed and i have to say that
although i was a biology major from
china and i knew i know as i would say
sort of undergraduate level molecular
biology and genetics but to me this
whole genome-wide genomics is very new
and statistics is also very new to me so
i was just a fresh star having to learn
everything
and this was a picture from peter hayes
and co team and i was here and ben brown
was there and piong hyung are in the
middle so ben will give a talk this
afternoon that was i think around 2011
2012.
so i want to say that this is the fruit
when i was part of the team so we are
part of the statistics team in encode
and berkeley had this news in 2012 to
introduce our contribution and peter's
name is in the second paragraph
and fortunately i was part of the team
and as a result at the time of my
graduation these four papers i was part
of them and they are all related to the
encode i have to say i learned so much
from the process and from the
supervision of petron haiyan especially
i'm very grateful that they gave me this
opportunity to learn from them otherwise
i might be doing something totally
different at this time
okay so even back then i had these
questions which has been i would say i
have been thinking about them constantly
until now and the first question is are
p values valid so in all our textbook
examples we learn how to define a
p-value how to calculate it but as nancy
pointed out the biological questions are
more complicated so then this question
has been has bothered me for a long time
and i will show one example and the
second question i had was why not
starting with classical statistical
methods because for a lot of the
bioinformatics methods i read about
during the anco phase i was always like
can we solve it with something simpler
and i will show one example for that and
finally this is in line with what nancy
just presented what is the proper null
hypothesis
because if we have different null as the
default we may get different answers
from our statistical inference so i will
show one example for each question
okay so from now on i will focus on the
statistical rigor in multiple testing
because if you know fdr has been one of
the most well cited paper the benjamini
hotspot paper because of multiple
testing is so popular in bioinformatics
so in multiple testing we work with
p-values one p-value per test per
hypothesis
but if p-values are well calibrated they
should follow uniform distribution
between 0 and 1 or at least super union
form distribution
if we are being conservative
and then if we want to aggregate the
multiple tests and do one set of
decisions the aggregate criterion which
is mostly popular is the false discovery
fdr it also needs calibration otherwise
we are not really achieving what we
claim like five percent fdr
okay and i want to list three common
causes i have seen over the years about
why p values might be u post so the
first common cause is what i call the
formulation of a two sample test as a
one sample test
so this is what we call the chip
sequencing data which nancy also briefly
showed in her encode introduction so
here we have two conditions from each
condition we obtain a cheap sequencing
chip seek sample so here the sorry here
the x-axis
is our genome and the y-axis can be
considered as the binding intensity of
one protein to different regions in the
genome so the question here is if we do
comparison between the two conditions
can we call this region a peak by a peak
we mean that the protein binds to this
region more intensively in the
experimental condition like the
condition of our interest than in the
background condition so it's a
comparison problem
and when i was a phd student at berkeley
there were two methods that were
published especially the max method it
was something we actually read about in
our group meeting journal club so it was
from shirley news group at harvard it
has been the most popular method and you
can see the citation
so even though the method has some
complicated data processing steps but i
try to simplify the statistical part
using this table so in other words we
look at one region so this box can be
considered as one region
and we summarize the intensity values
into a count value under each condition
each sample so we get an x for the
background count y for the experimental
count and i use the capitalization to
refer to them as random variables
and these are not really observed with
their distributions but we do get one
observation for each random variable i
call them small x small y
so how the max method calculates the p
value for this region is using this way
so it considers the count
experimental count which is our interest
random variable
follows a poisson distribution under the
null hypothesis with the parameter as
the x small x which is the background
observation and then we want to know
under this poisson distribution what is
the right tail probability that this big
y is less greater or equal than the
observed small y so i saw this p-value
definition back then and i was very
confused i have to say i was wondering
is this the correct p-value
after thinking it through i do not think
so because essentially what it does is
that it assumes y follows a poisson
distribution with parameter lambda and
the hypothesis is that under the null
lambda equals small x alternative lambda
equals big x this can justify why the
p-value formula is like this however you
can see that the null hypothesis
involves x small x and considers to be a
fixed value but we know that this small
x is a random observation so that's why
i said here the randomness of small x is
ignored in other words we are treating
this two sample testing problem as a one
sample testing problem
okay so i had that doubt back then but i
didn't have a fit i don't know how i can
fix this p-value issue because this
scenario is essentially a two-sample
comparison problem but each sample has
only a size of one how can i do a test
with one versus one comparison i didn't
learn this from textbook and i think we
must rely on some very strong parametric
assumption
and i think p-value calculations are
difficult so even though i doubt it but
i didn't have a fix
until
when i listened to emmanuel can this
talk about knock-offs i figured out wow
yeah if we just want to control the fdr
p values are intermediates they are not
the final targets can we get rid of the
p values but directly control the fdr
yeah so motivated by the knockoff fdr
procedure control procedure which i will
elaborate so we came up with this paper
published in genome biology last year
trying to solve this problem for many
such comparison problems without going
through high resolution p values so i
was very happy that we figured this out
after so many years
okay that's the first
cause the second cause is what i see as
the specification of a parametric model
that does not fit data well so another
cause of eopostp values so this is a
different application problem where we
want to identify differentially
expressed genes from rna sequencing data
so here we can see that
we're still doing a two condition
comparison and here each condition we
have three experimental replicates and
every column is a gene so which means
that we're going to compare each gene's
two sets of measurements and see if the
string is differentially expressed
between the two conditions so roughly
the left gene is differentially
expressed the right gene may not be
so for this simple problem right
seemingly simple there are two popular
softwares that dominate the field
dc2 and hr and i have to say that they
are both developed for small sample
sizes like this three versus three
problems we know that when sample size
are so small we do a statistic test we
don't have a good estimate for the
variance the variance estimate will have
very large variance right so in this
case people usually do empirical base
they try to borrow information across
genes to stabilize the variance estimate
and moreover for each gene each method
both methods i should say assume that
the gene follows a negative binomial
distribution under each condition so
even though with only three values it's
very hard to say whether this negative
binomial distribution works or not that
is the assumption
okay so people use these methods but i
actually
in a collaborative project with a
computational biologist dr weive at uc
irvine we found by accident that
so interestingly from this immunotherapy
data set from cell 2017 so here the
sample sizes are much bigger so we have
51 and 58 in the two groups so we found
that if we randomly shuffle the group
label condition labels and we run the
e62 and hr for many cases the two
methods can find more d genes from
permeated data than from the original
data so that raised a caution we were
wondering what's going on
and to look into this issue and figure
out whether these the discoveries these
two methods made from the original data
might be false discoveries
we checked the model fitting right
because here the sample sizes are
reasonably large we can check how well
does the negative binomial model for
every gene fits the data in each
condition
yeah and we found that for the genes
that are frequently identified from
permedia data the fitting was poor
for the genes that are rarely identified
from permitted data the fitting was
better so this ids confirms that the
model fitting is the issue here negative
binomial distribution does not hold well
on this data set because here the
samples under each condition are
individuals not experimental replicates
so that can explain why the theoretical
negative binomial distribution which may
make sense for replicates does not fit
well for population
human population data
and then for biologists they always ask
me so what what's the consequence then
we show them that if we pretend that we
didn't know there might be issues with
the d genes found by d62 and hr we just
take those genes and run the we call the
functional enrichment analysis trying to
see which biological pathways are
related to those genes we can actually
see that many pathways are immune
related so therefore if we trust the
result we can report a very good finding
right yeah there's immune response
differences between the two groups of
patients with immunotherapy and without
or without immunotherapy that can
totally change the story
so i think this is very interesting and
because i i always had this question why
not classical statistical methods so i
just suggested to my collaborator how
about we try the wilcoxon rank sometimes
and we can see that wilcoxon doesn't
have this issue it doesn't find you find
zero d genes from the real data it also
finds zero d genes from all permeated
data so in other words we don't see
anything unreasonable
so we publish this work in march this
year and we can see the number of
accesses means that the field is really
interested in this problem
and although this is something we all
know in this community in the audience
for large sample size data
non-parametric methods can be an option
but i want to say that in the
bioinformatics community people are
mostly driven by a method popularity
right people go with the majority
instead of like like instead of being
checking the assumptions like what we
recommend them doing
okay so that's the large sample size
because here permutation can give us a
lot of null possibilities for us to
check false positives what if the sample
size are spot back to the original
setting 3 replicates each condition so i
want to say that in this case we want to
propose our clipper as a non-parametric
option for calibrating the fdr control
even though we go with parametric
methods like d62 and hr which i will
show later
okay that's the second cause
the third cause about eo pulse p-value
is the treatment of inferred covariate
as observed this is a very common issue
in genomic data analysis so here i'm
moving to single cell rna sequencing
data which nancy also introduced so here
a typical analysis is called the
pseudo-time differential expression
analysis what does it mean so we define
cell studio time which i think is very
innovative so it was proposed by
a berkeley cs phd graduate cotragno in
his postdoc work now he's at u
washington so they propose this concept
called cell pseudotime which is a latent
unobserved temporal variable that is
supposed to reflect a cell's relative
status among all cells to infer the
pseudotime this test is called time
inference is to estimate the suit time
of all cells and the approach is to
order cells along a trajectory based on
these cells high dimensional gene
expression vectors so that's the task
and monaco 3 is the pioneer for doing
this and
sandrine's slingshot is a popular
software nowadays for doing this task so
this is an illustration from the
slingshot paper
essentially we first do damage reduction
of cells so we can project cells from
high dimensional space to a low
dimensional principle component space
and then the algorithm called minimum
spanning tree is applied to connect the
cell which are pre-clusters to connect
the cell clusters and then the tree is
smoothed out by the principal curves and
finally each branch of the principal
curve is considered as one trajectory by
trajectory we mean that it may refer to
cell differentiation or you may refer to
sales
immune responses right depending on the
context so by projecting every cell to
its closest trajectory we can obtain the
coordinates in the trajectory which will
be normalized between zero and one
called pseudotime
okay so this is the pseudo time and
these dots are sales and we are showing
one gene in each panel so basically the
y-axis is gene expression levels we can
see that if we look at the trend the
left gene should be considered as
differentially expressed along
pseudotime the right gene may not so why
are we interested in doing this the
reason is that we believe the
pseudo-time refers on biological process
like differentiation then we will be
interested in which genes are driving
this process or are correlated with this
process then we need this differential
expression identification
okay so one thing i want to point out
when i read this line of literature is
that i found maybe we should consider
the inference uncertainty of cell studio
time so let's look at this toy example
this is a very simple
one branch studio time and if we
consider the standpoint uncertainty
which we heard about yesterday and here
i reflect the sampling uncertainty by
just doing subsampling of the cells and
in each subsample i redo the pseudotime
inference so for each cell i would
obtain its pseudo times across the
subsamples for which it's included so we
can see there is a dispersion right so
it's not one value but there's some
uncertainty that's the sample
uncertainty
however i want to point out up to when
we started working on this
to our knowledge existing method treats
pseudotime as an observed covariate
instead of
inferred covariate
so for this task we proposed this method
to cause pseudotime de to consider the
uncertainty of studio time inference
so this is led by my student don juan
and so in short we actually
our method was built upon let me say the
traceq method which was also from
sandrine's group and they used the
generalized additive model to be the
non-linear regression approach to
capture the relationship between every
gene and the pseudotype so here is the
procedure so we started with the cells
we first do pseudo time inference to get
a trajectory infer trajectory and then
we can fit a gam model to every gene j
so here for the generalized part the
distribution we consider both negative
binomial and zero inflated negative
binomial because our gene expression are
counts
so after fitting the model we can obtain
a test statistic from the model
so if we don't assume the student time
to be random we are done here so we can
use the test statistic use the
theoretical null distribution and we get
a p-value however our argument is that
here the theoretical distribution may
not hold anymore because of the
randomness in pseudotime so therefore
for the top part we try to generate an
empirical null distribution
so we use the subsampling approach
instead of the bootstrap approach
because some pseudotime inference
methods do not allow for repetitive
cells so bootstrap is not an option but
we do sub sampling with 80 percent of
the cells for each subsample we do
single time inference so pseudo time
inference is part of the whole pipeline
we want to do inference for and then
based on the inverse studio time we want
to disrupt the relationship between the
gene and the cell time to create the
null cases so we permeate the cells so
any relationship if existent will be
disrupted then from these data we fit
the gan model the same get model as here
and then the test statistic values on
each permeated subsample will be from
the node so that can give us the null
distribution empirical null distribution
and we can get a p-value so this is a
very simple idea but actually it works
so we can show that with this
calibration
we can make sure the p-values are
uniform between 0 and 1 under the null
and compared to the state of the r
method 36 and monocle 3 the e we can
show that this p value calibration can
give us some actual use
we can show that the difference in the d
genes between the methods so like the
djs our method can uniquely find will
actually have some useful i would say
reasonable gene ontology functional
terms that can help us interpret the
results much better so i would say this
shows the use of calibration p values in
real applications
however i want to say that this method
has its limitations the obvious one is
the computational time we can see that
if we want to get high resolution
p-value say
0.001 we need at least 1 000 rounds
right so that can be time-consuming so
here i want to say that our clipper
again offers an fdr control approach by
reducing the number of rounds we don't
have to do so many null generation
and another thing we didn't consider yet
is the other null the more complete no
which means that in our case we just
consider now to be that a gene has no
relationship with pseudotime but what if
the cells don't follow a trajectory at
all the cells are just iid no trajectory
but in that case our node doesn't
capture so to capture additional we need
a way to generate those complete null
cells so for this we propose a simulator
to generate the null under this more
complete null case
and besides suit time d
a related problem is
which is also a common practice in the
field is that we want to first divide
cells into clusters just like in the
network problems we heard about
community detection it's also a type of
clustering problem with the clusters
then we infer which genes are
differentially expressed between two
clusters so for this problem in the
state of the art in the field it's just
by pretending clusters are predefined
they are class they're they're classes
instead of clusters so that we ignored
that the clusters are learned from the
same data
but there are methods that account for
this and they use the selected inference
framework so so it's from david's test
group from stanford and also daniella
witness group from washington
that they both assume that the genes are
following gaussian distributions so this
is an
assumption we hope to relax or remove
so here is our proposal we want to use
essay design 3 to generate a set of
model cells and then we want to use
clipper to achieve fdr control without
relying on high resolution key values
and i want to say that this was inspired
by the gap statistic paper which was for
setting up no controls to find the
number of clusters and i remember
high-end introduced paper to this paper
to me when i was a phd student and also
of course the knockoff procedure which
is the theoretical foundation for us
okay so this is a summary of what i said
so i talked about three common causes of
u postp values and for the remaining
time i'll try to be quick and talk about
our solutions so first i'll quickly
introduce clipper which i consider to be
a p-value-free fdr control general
procedure for genomics feature screening
and we use the fdr control theorem from
barbers and canvas from their knockout
paper
so in short
clipper only requires two components
contrast scores and a cutoff so for the
contrast scores let's say we have d
features every feature we need to give
it a contrast score so that the
distribution contrast square should
follow the shape which is the
theoretical foundation for the fdr
control in the knock of paper so in
other words if a pitch features a null
feature its contrast score should be
symmetric around zero in other words the
absolute value of the contrast score
should be independent of the sign
and for the features that are likely
interesting their contrast scores should
be largely positive on the right tail so
with this then this thresholding or
cutoff result was from the knockoff
paper so we leveraged this result but we
don't need to generate knockoffs as in
their paper because their case is more
complicated it's about a multivariate
prediction problem but in our case we're
doing just marginal feature screening so
we're looking at one feature at a time
so our hope is to get rid of the you the
need for high resolution key values or
parametric assumptions we can hardly
verify or large sample sizes required
for non-parametric statistics
okay so this is the key summary of this
method idea we need the target data and
the null data to set up contrast so in
the first example gcp calling the
experimental condition and the
background condition naturally sets up a
contrast so i don't need to do any data
generation
in the rna sequencing dg identification
problem we showed that the permeated
data can be used as no data the actual
data is the target data and in the two
single cell problems the actual data is
the target data and the null data will
be simulated from our simulator based on
the specified node
so the contrast can be established by
applying some
informative summary statistics to both
target data and no data and do a
contrast and i want to know that this t
summary statistic in reality can be a
complex pipeline because in the field
data processing is part it's very
important and this can be hardly
summarized like in a mathematical way so
i can say it can be a complex pipeline
so let's show the result applying
clipper to max and homer and these 62 hr
as an add-on so using whatever the
output and way set up the contrast and
control fdr we can see that
we can greatly reduce their actual fdr
to be equal or below the target fdr
that's what we aim to achieve while we
don't sacrifice too much power so the
power is still reasonable
so these two results actually show that
this idea can be a very powerful and
flexible approach for leveraging the
power of existing methods while
rectifying their fdr
okay
but i didn't touch the last part yet so
for the single cell part how can we
generate the null data using our
simulator
so that's the last piece
our simulator so i want to say that the
foundation of the simulator was our last
year's work we call acid design two it's
a probabilistic single cell gene
expression data simulator so for every
gene we allow the model selection from
four count distributions poisson
negative binomial and they are zero
inflated versions we fit each model
marginally for each gene per cell type
so here cell types are predefined cells
are clusters but we want to relax this
next slide and the key is that we are
using a probabilistic model using a
technique called gaussian copula so we
can capture gene gene correlations which
was not really the emphasis in previous
simulators and also i want to say that i
first heard about copula when i was in
peter's group from our poster chun hua
lee's work and she's currently at penn
state university so i learned a lot from
her
so
we found that copula plays a crucial
role so this is the data used for
fitting our model this is the left out
data untouched and this is the synthetic
data from our simulator with gaussian
copula without gaussian copula you can
see the data look very different and
these are two state-of-the-art
simulators that do not explicitly
capture correlations but we still
compare them to show yeah here this
explicit modeling of correlation is
important
okay but this is not perfect right we
only consider discrete cell types and as
my previous part said the sales may
follow a continuous trajectory
so we expanded that simulator to our
third version so now you can see that
with this continuous we use the get
model again generalized additive model
as the baseline as the backbone of the
simulator we can see that yeah we can
generate cells along a continuous
trajectory so that can mimic real data
better than our previous simulator which
generate data from discrete cell types
and furthermore we are no longer
restricted to just rna sequencing data
we can work with attack sequencing nc
mentioned is about the open chromatin
signatures or even protein data or even
spatial coordinates data and also here
we make sure that we can output a
likelihood so we can do likelihood-based
model selection for this we use the wine
copula technique so that we can output
the likelihood for the multivariate
model
so this is one example this is a spatial
data example we can see that it works
very well for this one we use the
two-dimensional generalized additive
model as the backbone
and also we
thanks to my junior student guangao we
actually added the functionality so we
cannot just output
not only just outputting counts but also
the reads the raw level data so the read
this is the synthetic data this is the
real data we can show that with the
reads we can even benchmark those
computer science
low-level processing pipelines not just
the statistical parts with count data
all right so with the simulator then we
can generate no data so for example this
is the real data with apparently two
clusters but if we want to generate a
null without any clusters we can merge
them using our simulator it's just
changing the parameters in our
probabilistic model which i think is
very flexible
and this is the example where the real
data we just want to show the effect is
actually one cluster one cell type no
clusters and if we don't assume we know
this we just do
k equals two clustering using the
dominant pipeline cirrht or the k-means
clustering we can always divide the
cells into two clusters and do d gene
analysis we can find d genes
but if we use our simulator to generate
null data as a control in this case we
can see the null data will look like
real data because the real data doesn't
have a cluster
so you see that if we
force these existing pipelines to find d
genes with k equals two the fdr is equal
to one because they will always find d
genes even though there are no two
clusters but using our contrast approach
we can control the fdr very well because
we set up the proper null
all right so that's the major part of my
talk i want to summarize here so i want
to say that p values can be easily
imposed in genomics data analysis
but before we talk about p values i
think a more important question is
should a scientific question be
formulated as multiple testing for this
question we actually i collaborated with
dr shintong at ufc who was also rachel's
collaborator and who was professor
jianjin fan student so you can see we
have a social network here among
researchers working on different things
so we actually so from my conversation
with shin we both realized that our
students and our my biology
collaborators are often confused about
whether some multiple binary decision
problems should be formulated as a
multiple testing problem or as a binary
classification problem so facing that
issue we wrote this article to
conceptually distinguish their uses and
their
application domains
so if we answer is yes yeah we should
formulate this as a multiple testing
problem in other words multiple
inference problems then i talked about
the three causes using three examples
and i proposed this fdr control
framework motivated by the knockoff and
our simulator for generating no control
beyond that the simulator can provide a
way for fair benchmarking of
computational tools we can see that from
this website the single cell field has
more than one thousand tools already so
offering users some guidance is
necessary
all right so these are the publications
i mentioned in my talk
and finally this is something i want to
share because i know in this audience we
have so many luminary statisticians so i
want to hear your thoughts about this
problem and i welcome any any comments
so this is another work i didn't talk
about today it's about a problem in
statistical genetics called qtl mapping
and there were several methods proposed
for inferring hidden variables from a
matrix like uh individual by jinx
russian matrix right so and several
popular methods were proposed over the
last decade and i have to say my student
heather i'm really thankful for her
because it was during a problem a
project where she was supposed to use a
hidden variable inference method as part
of the problem but she's so
detail-oriented she said oh i need to
understand the method before i use it so
she'd study this method and she found by
surprise that pca actually is the best
so at least by our comprehensive
simulations so in other words we wrote
this article and we showed our results
and our paper was i would say
enthusiastically reviewed and this was
one anonymous reverse comment these
results may come as a surprise to some
given the nearly uncontestable status
that method a has achieved within the
community but sadly they reflect the
fact that computational biology methods
can rise to fame almost by accident
rather than by young statistical
arguments
so i think this is a problem that we
should address right if we think we can
provide sound statistical arguments then
how can we make our voice be heard how
can we change the practices so
statistics is more i would say pay more
attention or receive a higher status in
the scientific community
so finally i want to thank my advisors
peter and haiyan for yeah for inviting
me here to give this talk and of course
my collaborators
dr wade and his postdoc you may at uc
irvine because without their
collaboration i wouldn't find a
scientific way to justify yeah wilcoxon
is the way to go or will cause is the
way for that application or how we can
justify pca is better because i think we
need to use their language to come
convince the users and also my poster
shinzo and former student elim for their
work on clipper and shinjuku for the
djinn part and tien yi and don yuan for
their work on the simulators and for
dongle and for the co2 as well and also
the funding agencies for support my
research thank you very much
thank you very much
so finally i understand what my
public transportation clipper card is
doing so
any questions or comments
i mean you have
made a very interesting point of course
also at the end right that um
sound statistical arguments are maybe
more
uh or should be taken more into account
i mean you you work hard in
communicating that uh i mean what is
your this more high level comment what
is your experience when you
show these things to your more
bioinformatics collaborators i should
say
the hr
author mark robinson is my colleague at
zurich so i definitely will tell him
about it
but can you maybe expand a bit or you
think this needs more
yeah nah
i don't know publication is one way of
communication yeah that we speak up more
or people like you
yeah thank you i think mark robinson
must be aware of that that our work
because we had a lot of twitter
conversations with other bms authors on
twitter and i think these are very
helpful to me because i think i feel
like i wouldn't i want to i think the
key message is not is that it's not like
we're saying d62 and hr do not work but
they have their application domains so
we have to just let users be able to
choose appropriate method for specific
data set but i understand that's very
difficult for users because they're not
statisticians so i feel one message we
want to convey from that paper is the
importance of collaborating with the
statistician for the method choice and
also i think another thing i want to say
about the communication with
bioinformaticians
or i would say yeah bioinformaticians
are more better better collaborators we
can communicate with than experimental
biologists because compound
inflammations use methods so they can
understand what we are talking about but
for experimental biologists the gap is
even bigger so we need to yeah i think
the gap is even bigger but anyway i want
to say that what i learned from dr wily
my collaborator is that he always asked
me
so what he said you said what but so
what what's the consequence what's the
scientific consequence so i think the
reason why our paper about the d gene
comparison can receive such considerable
attention was because we use that
immunotherapy data set because that data
shows a striking difference using
different methods and the scientific
conclusion is so important that can
raise the scientists you know attention
to pay attention to the problem so i
feel like showing the scientific
community the importance of using
statistics in a more rigorous way is a
way to to advocate our methods that's my
that's my
my point
thank you and see yeah
so
i think this is a great talk and
wonderful work
but one thing that i ran into um just
talking to the biology community one one
problem as you
described is that
p values that are not accurate get
thrown around
but the other problem is just that um i
think as a field
they pay a little attention to p values
in a sense that um in these high
throughput
experiments you have fdr it narrows down
to maybe the top few hundred genes oh
which passes because there's just so
much signal
and then um they pick the ten that has
the most uh it doesn't have to be the
top ten to do some high throughput
experiments on those ten gets done one
by each
undergrad or post doc and then in the
end the paper focuses on one yeah that's
right so um
what are your thoughts are on the role
of p-value yeah in these studies thank
you yeah that's a very good question i
also had a lot of discussion with people
on this interestingly as people i think
one biologist just explicitly told me i
don't trust p values but we need them we
need them to justify our procedure to
say oh that's how we get to that one
discovery so i don't like this i feel
like they are using statistics more like
a declaration or like a rhetoric rather
than
scientific argument so but i want to say
that i didn't show the result here but
we do have results showing that it's not
just the threshold changing using
different fdr control procedures it can
also change the ranking so if we change
the ranking the top ones may be
different like in that
immunotherapy case right if we use the
wilcoxon we may think there's no genes
to be verified we need to maybe increase
the sample size and then do the analysis
again but if we use dc2 we will be super
enthusiastic and go ahead and do the
experiment so i think that can change
the practice yeah i agree i feel like
what we need to tell them is that it's
not just publishing papers it can change
the scientific conclusion and hopefully
they will be convinced but my personal
experience is that it's easier to
convince computational biologists than
experimental biologists because they
understand our tools much better yeah
thank you for the comment
okay
so
uh let's thank both speakers again for
their night
and it's lunch time
and we will resume at 140 sharp so
please don't be too late for the next
exciting session